economía en directo américa de france 24
y ya por fin después de tanta ausencia
llega nuevamente la reina de esta
sección daniela blandón dan y qué bueno
tenerte aquí nuevamente feliz lunes
gracias dicen que el buen hijo volvió a
casa bueno volvió la buena hija entonces
dan y vamos a hablar entonces de cuáles
son los retos económicos que le esperan
al próximo presidente de costa rica
teniendo en cuenta que ayer fue la
primera vuelta de estas elecciones y
teniendo en cuenta raúl también que ya
se sabe que va a haber una segunda
vuelta entre el ex presidente josé maría
figueres y el economista rodrigo chávez
pero independientemente de quien llegue
al poder pues va a tener varios retos
económicos por ejemplo la pobreza que
ante antes de la pandemia era del 21 por
ciento ahora desde el 23 por ciento y
afecta a más de 380 mil hogares unos
50.000 hogares han caído en esta
condición durante la crisis ahora la
pobreza extrema ha crecido incluso más
en 2019 era de 58 por ciento y ahora es
superior en medio punto porcentual en
cifras esto se traduce en que más de 10
mil personas cayeron en ella y ya son
unas 104 y personas que están en pobreza
extrema y el desempleo es del 13 7% un
nivel que se acerca lentamente al que
había al si hace dos años cuando inició
la pandemia y seguimos entonces con esta
sección de danny porque hoy hace 60 años
eeuu impuso el bloqueo económico a la
isla cuba claro raúl peso fue el 7 de
febrero de 1962 cuando entró en vigencia
el bloqueo que introdujo john f.kennedy
a la isla esto para complicar las
relaciones de cuba con el resto del
mundo por los vínculos que tenía el
gobierno con la entonces unión unión
soviética lo que incluyó el embargo es
que no se pueden hacer transacciones
legales en dólares ni comercializar con
productos que atraviesen eeuu o que
tengan un porcentaje de partes
elaboradas en ese país ni mucho menos
utilizar el sistema financiero
estadounidense
el gobierno dice raúl que eso le ha
costado casi 148 mil millones de dólares
en las últimas seis décadas a la isla
hoy en día cuba atraviesa por su peor
crisis en 30 años con una inflación
galopante del 70 y una marcada escasez
de alimentos y de medicinas pues muchos
culpan a washington otros culpan a la
buena y qué va a pasar entonces salimos
el acercamiento inicial en el gobierno
de obama después otra distancia en el
gobierno de donald trump y ahorita
parece que está todo en punto muerto ni
cerca ni lejos esperanza de que se
levante este bloqueo pues raúl es es un
embargo al que los cubanos ya casi que
están acostumbrados a vivir con él y con
muy pocas esperanzas de que se levanten
en un futuro cercano lo más flexible que
se ha visto hasta ahora ha sido barack
obama y nadie apretó tanto como donald
trump que impuso 243 medidas adicionales
y las promesas de joe biden que no ha
suavizado el bloqueo incluso aplicó
nuevas sanciones contra funcionarios
cubanos así que no sabemos qué va a
pasar bueno angustia dio a ser marcado
últimamente si ha salido aterrada
aterrada porque es compresión en este
país se está disparando pero como le
decía la de los alimentos muchísimo más
usted es la experta en el tema pues como
en casi todo el mundo se ha disparado la
inflación colombiano es la excepción y
la inflación acumulada en los últimos 12
meses hasta enero fue del 6,94 por
ciento según el instituto de estadística
muy parecido al resto de la región pero
dentro de ese total hay una cifra que si
prende todas las alarmas de las
autoridades económicas y es la variación
de los precios de los alimentos en
apenas un año fue del 20% esto es clave
porque dentro de la canasta familiar
casi la mitad de ese aumento en enero se
atribuye a la comida consumida en el
hogar danny estamos a las puertas de
unas presidenciales en colombia le
pregunto qué piensa hacer entonces este
gobierno saliente para tratar de paliar
esta inflación ahí hay algo que puede
hacer
bueno pues analistas dicen que esta
situación se debe a que a un menor
abastecimiento sobre todo por las
protestas y a un notable incremento de
los precios de los insumos importados el
ministerio de hacienda lo que ha dicho
es que va a tomar medidas para reducir
los costos de producción principalmente
del agro una promesa de mucho tiempo
atrás y que trabaja para bajar los
aranceles de la importación de insumos
del sector de alimentos veremos también
qué pasa vamos a ver qué pasa entonces a
daniela indica de las bolsas asiáticas
en cerraron con resultados planos al
regreso de las celebraciones del año
nuevo lunar con todas las bolsas
estabilizándose en medio de esta crisis
diplomática y en europa se registran
subidas después de cinco semanas
consecutivas a la baja gracias a las
ganancias de las acciones mineras danny
y que nos trae para finalizar como cifra
el día 72 mil millones de dólares estas
fueron las pérdidas del turismo en
australia desde el comienzo de la
pandemia ahora el sector está de fiesta
porque el gobierno anunció la reapertura
de fronteras a partir del 21 de febrero
puede ir empacando maletas o para
marruecos que también abrió claro que sí
bueno yo creo que prefiero primero
australia visitar a unos cuantos amigos
y después ahí de paso por paso por
marruecos gracias a cni por toda la
información económica nos vemos más
adelante con más economía vamos a ver
ahora nuestro reportaje